اعاده تعصين لتشغل العلم مره اخرى باخبار
كورونا او بالاحرار عدد كورونا تقلق
العالم ما بعد تعليق سياسه صفر كوميديه
شهدت الصين ارتفاعا واضحا في اعداد
الاصابات واثار تكدس المصابين في
المستشفيات الزهره من عوده سيناريو عام
[موسيقى]
والقلق بدا يتسرب خارج حدود الصين ويصل
هذه المره الى مجموعه من الدول التي بادرت
بسرعه الى اتخاذ اجراءات الاحتراضيه في
وجه القادمين من الصين وتزايد عدد الدول
التي تفرض قيود على القادمين من الصين
يرتفع الى 12 بلدا بعد ان انضمت استراليا
الى كل من الولايات المتحده وكندا
واليابان وبعض الدول الاوروبيه من بينها
فرنسا التي حثت دول الاتحاد الاوروبيه
الاخرى على اجراء اختبارات للمسافرين
القادمين من الصين وكان المغرب اعلن عن
حضر دخول المسافرين القادمين من الصين
اعتبارا من الثالث من يناير لتجنب موجه
جديده من العدوى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الارتفاع الاخير في عدد الاصابات يعود
بالاساس الى ظهور المتحولا جديد وهو ما
كانت كشفت عنه منظمه الصحه العالميه وتما
تصنيف المتحور على انه شديد العدوى
والانتشار كما انه سبب زياده حالات
الاصابات في الصين واوضح التقارير الطبيه
ان المتحوله الجديد يهاجم جهاز التنفسي
بشكل اقل من غيره لكنه ينتشر بشكل كبير
واطلقت مجموعه من العلماء تحذيرات من
المتحول الجديد هذا الذي يعتبر اكثر شراسه
مقارنه بالمتحورات الاكثر انتشارا في
الوقت الحالي وذلك نقلا عن تقرير لصحيفه
ديل ميل البريطانيه